good morning
today wednesday the 17th of march
detectives from ethics police's major
crime team have arrested
a 50 year old man on suspicion of the
indecent assault
a murder of stewart lubbock the man
who was arrested in cheshire continues
to be questioned
by our detectives following the arrest
we immediately notified the lubbock
family
this arrest is almost 20 years to the
day
in which stewart was found unconscious
in a swimming pool
following a party at a home in roydon
he later died in hospital
the arrest comes after significant new
information came to light
following our renewed appeal for
information and
offer of an enhanced reward which
coincided
with a major tv documentary broadcast in
february 2020
this information has led to us making an
arrest
and over the coming days we will be
contacting
all those who were present at the party
at the time as well as others who may
have information
as we stated last february and have
continually stated
over the last 20 years we believe
someone
or some people at that party know
what happened it is important to restate
the fact
that essex police have never given up on
this case
and that the force is motivated by the
desire to deliver justice
for mr lubbock and his family stuart's
rape and murder
has been an extremely lengthy and
complex investigation
which has spanned over 20 years and
remains ongoing
we have never given up on finding out
exactly what happened
to stuart and we will not stop in our
pursuit of justice
for him and for his family and friends
as we said a year ago and have
repeatedly said
over the last 20 years nine people
were at that party we know that not
everyone was responsible for what
happened
but someone was now is the time to come
forward if you haven't done so already
to set this matter to rest by providing
us with any information you have
thank you very much